who is the greatest billionaire
entrepreneur of all time you guys get to
decide what's up believe nation at 7:00
I believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so up today we're
looking at Jeff Bezos versus Pierre
Omidyar who do you think is the greatest
up first is Jeff Bezos with a net worth
of a hundred and thirty seven billion
dollars he went from working on Wall
Street the founding amazon.com the
world's most valuable company on a
cross-country road trip and becoming the
richest man on the planet he's up
against Pierre Omidyar who's worth ten
point five billion dollars who went from
working for Claire as an Apple Computer
subsidiary to found an eBay and becoming
a billionaire at the age of 31 also if
you want to know what Jeff Bezos and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below the stress
primarily comes from not taking action
so let's kick it off with Jeff Bezos
rule number one take bold bets my job
one of my jobs as the leader of Amazon
is to encourage people to be bold and
people love to focus on things that
aren't yet working and that's good it's
human nature that kind of divine
discontent can be very helpful but you
really you know it's incredibly hard to
get people to take bold bets and you
need to encourage that and if you're
gonna take bold bets they're gonna be
experiments and if they're experiments
you don't know ahead of time though
they're gonna work
experiments are by their very nature
prone to failure but big success is a
few big successes compensate for dozens
and dozens of things that didn't work so
you know bold bets AWS Kindle Amazon
Prime our 3rd party seller business all
of those things are examples of bold
bets that that did work and they pay for
a lot of experiments I've made billions
of dollars of failures at amazon.com
literally billions of dollars of
failures and you know you might remember
pets calm or
Cosmo or you know give myself a root
canal with no anesthesia very easily
none of those things are fun but but
they also they don't matter what really
matters is companies that don't
continue to experiment companies that
don't embrace failure they eventually
get in a desperate position where they
only thing they can do is make a kind of
Hail Mary bet at the very end of their
corporate existence where as companies
that are you know making bets all along
even you know big bets but not bet the
company bets I don't I don't believe in
bet the company bets that's when you're
desperate that's that's the last thing
you can do over to Pierre Omidyar rule
number one just go and do it
when you look at the accomplishments of
accomplished people and you say boy that
must have been really hard you know when
you look at something that looks hard
that was probably easy and conversely
when you look at something that looks
easy that was probably hard and so
you're never gonna know which is which
until you actually go and do it so just
go and do it
try learn from it you know you'll fail
at some things that's a learning
experience that you need so that you can
take that on to the next experience and
don't let people who you may respect and
who you believe know what they're
talking about don't let them tell you it
can't be done because often they will
tell you it can't be done and it's just
cuz they don't have the courage to try
it back to Jeff Bezos rule number two
focus on your customers the secret sauce
of Amazon where there several principles
at Amazon but the number one thing that
has made us successful by far is
obsessive-compulsive focus on the
customer as opposed to obsession over
the competitor and I talk so often to
other CEOs and some other CEOs and also
founders and entrepreneurs and I can
tell that even though they're talking
about customers they're really focusing
on competitors and it is a huge
advantage to any company if you can stay
focused on your customer instead of your
competitor and back to Pierre Omidyar
rule number two don't take no for an
answer
there's something about entrepreneur and
is somewhat sort of anti-establishment
somewhat is respectful of the previous
generation and although that can great
people the wrong way a little bit and
it's a really important element actually
you need to be passionate about what you
want to work on and and don't take no
for an answer when when people out there
are giving you advice and say no this
will never work I mean yeah you look at
eBay the idea that that in 1995 that you
could create something over the Internet
which is this brand new thing that
nobody you know it was really using at
the time except for scientists and
academics and and it would be a place
where strangers can actually do business
with one another could actually like
exchange merchandise from firms for
money without ever meeting you know and
the notion that people could actually
buy in some cars over the internet
that's crazy right it's totally crazy so
in fact the lots and lots of people told
me that was crazy and I didn't you know
I have to say I didn't have this vision
oh it's gonna take over the world it's
gonna be this fantastic thing overnight
I didn't have that kind of delusion
either by but I didn't say you know and
there's something there's something
worth trying here it's not it's not
crazy now I've got two really special
bonus rules from Jeff and Pierre on how
to be resourceful and know your mission
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that I want to know who you
voting for who moves on to round 2
Jeff Bezos or Pierre Omidyar let me know
in the comments below I spent an unusual
amount of time with my grandparents and
especially with my grandfather on the
ranch so he had a ranch in South Texas
and I would spend my summers there from
age 4 to 16 and they when I was four
they were taking me for the summer to
kind of give my parents a break you know
it's sort of because they were so young
and it was useful and I was a handful
I'm sure and anyway he he he created the
illusion for me when I was 4 years old
that I was helping him on the ranch
which of course could not have been true
but I believed it and and then as by the
time I was
sixteen of course I was actually helping
on the ranch I you know I can fix
prolapsed cattle I can you know we did
all of our own veterinary work some of
the cattle even survived and we fixed
windmills and laid you know water
pipelines and built fences and barns and
fixed the bulldozer that you guys talked
about and so one of the things that's so
interesting about that lifestyle and
about my grandfather is he did
everything himself you know he didn't
call of that if one of the animals was
sick he figured out what to do himself
and so what does it mean no delegation
being resourceful I think is the you
know that you can always you can't if
there's a problem there's a solution and
of course issue is you mature and and
get into the business world and anything
you do on a team you very quickly
realize that it's not about just your
own resourcefulness it's about team
resourcefulness and how does that work
and what I realized through the eBay
experience was that people are hungry
for personal communication and personal
relationships that they can build around
the shared area of interest and I
received hundreds of letters thousands
of letters from from eBay users that say
you know eBay's restored my faith in
humanity I've met my best friends on
eBay you know there have been people
that have been married that have met on
eBay I mean it's it's a little bit it's
a little bit strange it's definitely not
the you know the majority of the of the
users but there's something special
going on there and I think what it is is
when you give people a forum in which to
communicate and communicate around a
shared area of interest no matter you
know what socioeconomic classes they
come from what neighborhoods they come
from or geographies they realize that
they're human beings and they realized
that they can be a community together so
what we want to do with our philanthropy
is to just help people rediscover that
in especially in America I think we've
lost a lot of that in America it's
something that here in Europe we're a
lot more familiar with or a lot more
comfortable with the notion of an
individual being a part of a community
and having a responsibility to be a part
of that community in America
through a very you know a variety of
reasons that I won't go into here I have
some thoughts on it you know people have
become isolated and people are afraid to
talk to their neighbors sometimes but at
the core people do want to be part of a
community and all we have to do now is
figure out how to how to kind of
rekindle that a little bit and that's
that's our mission we've got you know
I'm young I'm 33 years old my wife and I
are 33 years old we've got at least 50
good years ahead of us to work on this
and it's gonna be a lifetime pursuit my
last round one video was Oprah Winfrey
against Gabe Newell if you want to go
cast your vote there to go check out the
link next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there your real work is to figure out
where your power bases